[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 le tour d'horizon
de l'actualité locale et régionale en 26
minutes
tout de suite les titres de ce mardi 13
mars l'ouverture aujourd'hui du 20ème
congrès de l'union départementale de la
cgt des yvelines il se tient jusqu'à ce
jeudi aux mureaux l'occasion de dresser
le bilan des dernières actions et de
parler des prochaines mobilisations le
rendez-vous a débuté ce matin en
présence du secrétaire général de la cgt
philippe martinez et diminuer le trafic
de transit rendre plus attractif
l'activité commerciale ambitions de
voisins-le-bretonneux est la commune a
lancé jusqu'au 16 mars une concertation
publique sur la traversée de son centre
ville
le passage en zone 30 est notamment
envisagé une piste qui ne convainc pas
tout le monde
reportage enfin votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire le portrait de la semaine
est consacrée à dijon yvelinois qui font
du hip hop depuis quatre ans ils dansent
au sein d'une compagnie le meltin urban
crew est resté avec nous nous aurons
également à des invités dans ce journal
alexandra granjou qui coanime demain une
conférence sur la psychomotricité des
jeunes enfants c'est au prisme à
elancourt et nous devrons également avec
nous trois étudiants en médecine à
l'université à versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
un membre de l'association poèmes il
s'apprête à partir en bolivie pour une
action humanitaire
le 20ème congrès de la cgt des yvelines
s'est donc ouvert ce matin aux mureaux
près de 200 délégués syndicaux sont
présents sur les trois jours de réunions
au programme évoqué la situation
syndicale dans les yvelines mais aussi
les mobilisations à venir avec un invité
le secrétaire général de la cgt philippe
martinez et nicolas landry était sur
place ce matin
l'heure est au bilan de l'année 2010 est
pour la cgt des yvelines environ 150
délégués syndicaux ont échangé sur les
manifestations estivales contre les
ordonnances réformant le droit du
travail
des mobilisations qui n'ont pas touché
le projet du gouvernement
il ya eu des mobilisations
majoritairement soutenu par l'opinion
mais on n'a pas su encore à mener assez
de monde dans les mobilisations et c'est
ce qu'on travaille
voilà d'aller plus au contact des
salariés de rendre tous nos syndiqués
plus acteur de les informer sur les
grands enjeux les mobilisation était
importante
pas suffisamment encore pour faire
reculer le gouvernement
justement ce qui ce qu'il faut c'est
continuer à militer continuer à discuter
avec ses collègues de travail avec sa
famille avec ses amis pour pour faire
comprendre que bat toute cette situation
toutes ces attaques va sont pas normales
ce 20ème congrès de la cgt des yvelines
l'occasion de préparer les prochaines
mobilisations à l'image du jeudi 22 mars
pour protester contre le projet de
réforme ferroviaire avec l'ouverture à
la concurrence ou la fin du statut de
cheminot pour les nouveaux embauchés
et puis le 22 et une convergence de
lutte des cheminots des fonctionnaires
de l'énergie des entre-temps certaines
entreprises du privé donc c'est c'est
une étape où on va ensemble réfléchir
comment on donne des suites et comment
on élargit ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
et donc il ya besoin que le 22 mars soit
puissant mais également aussi une
mobilisation des associations d'usagers
et de la population plus largement au
delà des cheminots parce que le rapport
spinetta et
est-ce qu'il reprit par le gouvernement
c'est une attaque purement et simplement
du service public ferroviaire
une autre journée de mobilisation est
déjà prévue ce jeudi 15 mars par les
retraités les salariés des ehpad et les
aides à domicile
elle se tient jusqu'au 16 mars voisins
le bretonneux a lancé une concertation
publique en vue du réaménagement de son
centre ville parmi les pistes évoquées
le passage en zone 30 mais tout est les
riverains ne sont pas favorables aux
nouvelles idées proposées une réunion
publique avait lieu le jeudi 8 mars pour
faire le point et camille lambert
patrick jacq de patrick jacques de
dixmude et mickaël millero rue hélène
boucher et port royal si elles
paraissent tranquille en journée aux
heures de pointe
elles n'ont pas la même allure les
automobilistes de la vallée de chevreuse
les emprunter le flux important crée
souvent des ralentissements la
circulation de transit est gênante bien
entendu en même temps elle alimente
aussi nos commerces
voilà six voisins n'étaient plus
traverser ou plus et bien peut-être que
nos commerces ne serait pas aussi
n'aurait pas la même vitalité qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui on parle
dévoiement pas d'un contournement
parlant de voisins qui est bien sûr un
autre sujet qui met l'un n'exclut pas
l'autre
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment qu'on se
concentre sur cette traversée de mozart
je ne peux pas la laisser dans l'état
actuel la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux a donc lancé une
concertation pour réaménager cette zone
objectif harmoniser et apaiser la
circulation de cet axe structurant pour
la ville
une réunion publique a eu lieu jeudi 8
mars pour faire le point sur ce projet
c'est une rue qui est fréquenté
maintenant savoir si c'est vraiment un
problème c'est un petit peu ce que l'on
va essayer de comprendre aujourd'hui
pendant cette réunion plusieurs
commerces ont écouté avec attention les
débats sur ce centre ville c'est le cas
du gérant sur cette brasserie implanté
en face de la mairie
pour lui la ville doit investir
raisonnablement dans ce projet moi je
pense qu'on peut très bien réaménager le
centre village tout en restant dans des
choses simples refaire peut-être les
voies refaire peut-être un petit peu les
trottoirs mais pas partir dans des
budgets comme on a entendu deux millions
d'euros je pense que ça fait beaucoup
est ce que c'est vraiment nécessaire et
est ce que vraiment ça en a besoin
aujourd'hui j'en suis pas sur les
différentes propositions sont
consultables en mairie le projet prévoit
de diminuer la part de trafic de transit
réduire les vitesses tout en maintenant
l'activité commerciale du centre ville
un chantier que la mère espère voir
débuter en 2020 malgré les
revendications du groupe d'opposition
divers droite tous rassemblés pour
voisin qui demande notamment de ne pas
créer de nouvelles rues pour éviter la
concentration automobile dans la ville
et des images également sur ce sujet de
quentin le frère c'est le plus grand
salon international de l'immobilier
saint-quentin-en-yvelines y participent
le mipim 2018 a débuté aujourd'hui à
mardi au palais des festivals à cannes
24 mille participants plus de 3000
exposants et 100 pays représentés sur
quatre jours d'événements
l'agglomération va profiter du rendez
vous pour montrer ses cinq grands
projets immobiliers d'entreprise exposé
en hologramme participer à des
conférences est aussi organisé des
visites thématiques avec des
investisseurs internationaux
écoutez christine turcat de beauregard
invités du dernier à 7,8 échos d'aurélie
ronces
nous avons la chance donc de pouvoir
mettre en avant à la fois les grands
projets d'aménagement
l'offre de bureaux l'offre immobilier
d'entreprise comme vous venez de le dire
dans votre reportage et surtout
bénéficiant cette année d'une visibilité
internationale avec à la fois la ryder
cup donc compétition de golf en octobre
mais également les jeux olympiques et
par para olympiques en 2024
et cette année en fait le pavillon est
organisée avec un espace central pour
mettre vraiment en valeur cinq
thématiques qui sont justement les
grands événements internationaux
l'offre immobilière l'innovation les
transports et les concours
architecturaux c'est en ce moment la
grande semaine de la petite enfance a
rendez vous au national et pour la
troisième année consécutive et l'encours
se mobilisent pour cet événement bonsoir
alexandra gange où vous êtes la
directrice de la crèche collective
l'îlot câlin à elancourt vous co animée
demain mercredi à 20 heures une
conférence au prisme on peut voir la
fiche s'afficher je bouge tu bouges nous
bougeons abordera le thème de la
psychomotricité chez l'enfant de 0 à 3
ans on va en parler dans un instant déjà
un mot peut-être sur cette semaine de la
petite enfance quels sont les objectifs
et comment ça s'organise sur la commune
d'el en cours cette semaine
alors en fait c'est en lien avec un
projet national qui s'intitule donc la
grande semaine de la petite enfance et
il encourt cette année le service petite
enfance a souhaité y participer donc
comme vous l'avez dit à nouveau
aujourd'hui donc nous avons dans toutes
les structures
il y a des petits événements à droite à
gauche des ateliers et donc une
conférence demain qui s'adresse aux
familles ou en tout cas parents grands
parents de jeunes enfants et on va y
venir alors chaque année il ya un thème
aussi pour pour ces c semaine de la
petite enfance le thème retenu cette
année c'est la motricité on imagine une
thématique importante chez les jeunes
enfants
tristesse oui tout à fait voilà cette
année c'est sur la psychomotricité du
tout petit donc c'est le quotidien de
l'enfant donc la motricité c'est ce
qu'on vit au tous les jours tous les
jours avec les tout-petits qui bouge
ce qui saute qui court qui grandissent
qu'on va grandir sous nos yeux
voilà et le thème c'est ça c'est comment
l'enfant évolue et grandit de 0 à 3 ans
la principalement lendemain mercredi
vous qu elle aimerait donc la conférence
je bouge tu bouges nous bougeons sur le
thème de la psychomotricité
chez les jeunes enfants vous serez aux
côtés d'une psychomotricienne justement
elle s'appelle caroline besson pour
donner toutes les clés à nos
téléspectateurs
concrètement la psychomotricité c'est
quoi qu'est-ce qu'on question de quoi on
parle quand on parle de psychomotricité
alors quand on parle de psychomotricité
on parle de tout le développement moteur
mais aussi psychoaffectif du tout petit
c'est à dire comment le tout petit va se
mettre à bouger va se mettre à quatre
pattes par exemple va se mettre assis va
se mettre debout
voilà qu'est ce qui se passe dans son
corps pour qu'il arrive un jour à
devenir un petit bipèdes c'est à dire un
petit être qui marchent à 1 sur ses deux
pieds et tout ça c'est en lien avec
l'environnement tout ce qu'il vit autour
de lui ses parents ses grands parents sa
famille les personnes qui vont s'occuper
autour d'eux autour de lui en fait
qu'ils vont s'occuper de lui et ça est
en lien bien sûr certains liens entre le
corps et le psychisme exactement voilà
tout à fait un enfant qui va grandir
dans un environnement plutôt sain est un
enfant qui va grandir de façon
harmonieuse à la fois dans son esprit
mais aussi dans son corps chaque année
pour cette semaine de la petite enfance
vous proposer une conférence pourquoi
demain proposée cette conférence sur la
psychomotricité qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à choisir ce thème alors le thème
s'il a été choisi donc par rapport au
projet national
c'est lui qui définit le tout bouge en
fait c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle
donc nous avons suivi ce thème là voilà
tout simplement
qu'est ce que les parents est haute et
aussi demandeur est ce qui a peut-être
une méconnaissance sur ce thème de la
psychomotricité aujourd'hui alors oui il
y a les parents sont très demandeurs
aujourd'hui dans les structures on
accompagne beaucoup les familles sur
comment accompagner leurs propres
enfants dans leur évolution
on voit par exemple en tant que parent
beaucoup d'enfants qui sont rapidement
mis à 6 ou alors qu'on va très vite
aider à se mettre debout voilà on va
avoir tendance à agir beaucoup trop vite
nos adultes alors que l'enfant est
capable génétiquement et naturellement
ils capables de le faire seul vous le
disais ce un thème primordial à cet âge
là entre 0 et 3 ans on peut imaginer que
variante d'éventuels problèmes dans la
motricité de l'enfant vont se répercuter
sur sa vie d'adulte donc il est
important d'agir très vite tout à fait
exactement un enfant qui aurait une
psychomotricité très fluide tout petit
c'est un enfant qui va devenir un adulte
plutôt à l'aise dans son corps est aussi
à l'aise dans ses relations sociales
voilà un futur adultes de demain qui
sera bien dans la société
on le rappelle vous êtes directrice de
crèche où on connaît le rôle d'accueil
des crèches est ce que les crèches à
votre avis n'ont elles pas aux siens un
rôle d'information de prévention auprès
des parents justement sur des thèmes
comme la psychomotricité laisse si tout
à fait nous avons un rôle de prévention
c'est pour ça qu'on le fait voilà c'est
important que l'enfant puisse grandir de
façon harmonieuse mais que son parent
soit accompagnée voilà par des
professionnels donc c'est notre rôle oui
tout à fait dernière chose sur le
programme de demain vous serez donc aux
côtés de caroline besson comment vont se
dérouler vos différentes interventions
vous par exemple sur quoi allez-vous
parler demain alors deux dans l'ordre
caroline besson va intervenir tout
d'abord pour vraiment parler de toutes
les étapes du développement psychomoteur
d'un point de vue plutôt mécanique et
moi je vais plutôt parler de
l'environnement c'est-à-dire de la place
du parent de la place de l'adulte et du
milieu social afin du milieu en fait
dans le dans lequel l'enfant va grandir
des échanges avec les parents qui ont
des échanges voilà l'idée c'est vraiment
d'avoir un moment d'échangé avec les
parents grands-parents personnes qui
sont aussi des futurs parents et qui
sont intéressés par ce témoin et je
rappelle que cette conférence je bouge
tu bouges nous bougeons sur le thème de
la psychomotricité se tiendra demain
mercredi à 20 heures au prisme à
elancourt et on précise que l'entrée est
libre merci alexandra grand jour d'avoir
est avec nous mais mercier vous
directrice de la crèche collective l'île
aux câlins et l'encours et pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site internet de la ville
d'elancourt et les élèves de terminale
avaient jusqu'à ce soir 18 heures pour
valider leurs voeux sur la plateforme
d'admission post-bac parcours sup
l'orientation souvent un casse tête pour
les jeunes afin de les aider
trappes et le lycée de la plaine de
neauphle a organisé à vendredi à 9 mars
un forum à trappes ton avenir pour
découvrir les différentes opportunités
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
quentin le frère et camille lambert
bonjour mesdames messieurs
voudrait avoir un renseignement
concernant les ateliers à 21 ans jérémy
entame sa deuxième année de bts dans le
commerce et il est venu spécialement
aujourd'hui attrape au lycée de la
plaine de 9 pour préparer sa recherche
d'emploi
j'achète informations concernant le cv
la lettre de motivation savoir comme on
le réalise chercher l'information sur
certains secteurs d'activité sur
certaines filières ateliers conférences
et conseils l'événement attrape temps à
venir a réuni élèves dès la 3e étudiants
et une cinquantaine de professionnels
leur présenter des filières d'art par
exemple peu ou pas connus nous avons
également des services publics
représentés donc nous avons une grande
diversité de métiers et filières qui
sont présentés d'une part et d'autre
part nous avons des stands tenus par nos
propres élèves qui présentent leurs
réalisations
une journée portes ouvertes qui a
accueilli près de 1000 personnes
à l'issue de ces entretiens jérémy fait
le bilan bien formulé dans l'ensemble
nombreux professionnels rencontrés que
du bonus pour moi pour la suite et mes
études et ma première édition de cet
événement dédié à l'orientation un
rendez vous qui devrait revenir chaque
année une action humanitaire menée par
des jeunes de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines neuf étudiants
en 2e année de métier nous devons partir
pour l'amérique du sud en juillet
prochain la direction la bolivie pour
aider la population sur place dans un
centre communautaire de la ville de
cochabamba nous recevons trois d'entre
eux des minérais bonsoir vous êtes la
responsable de communication de ce
projet qui s'appelle c'est minhas nous
aurons également berti à ternat bonsoir
ça c' est la responsable santé de ce
projet et tristan garcia bonsoir concert
responsable logistique donc du projet
s'est mis à son va parler de ce projet
bien sûr de vos actions qui vont être
menées sur place petit tour de table
pour commencer pourquoi se lancer chacun
dans l' aventure non émis
qu'est ce qui vous a attiré dans cette
aventure alors déjà premièrement le fait
de se sentir utile
ce sera à notre échelle et à nos moyens
mais on a de l'énergie à revendre donc
on pourrait aider au moins au niveau
local et voilà avertis ou qui motivait
moi j'ai toujours voulu faire de
l'humanitaire et du coup c'est un
premier pas alors voilà comme dit nous
immiscer à notre échelle parce qu'on n'a
pas encore forcément les compétences
pour apporter des vraies actions de
santé mais c'est un premier pas dans
l'humanitaire quoi
tristan termine par autour de fable
ouais en fait allé en bolivie en tant
que touriste ou y aller en tant que
faire une action humanitaire c'est
complètement différent
j'avais jamais fait d'humanitaires et je
trouve ça une opportunité géniale y
aller pour une première fois d'être
vraiment au coeur de la population et
c'est encore mieux si on peut les aider
donc voilà alors sur le nom projet c'est
milla ce qu'est ce que ça signifie
pourquoi pourquoi ce nom alors bon on
aimait bien l'idée ça veut dire graines
en fait en espagnol qui est la langue
parlée en bolivie
on aimait bien l'idée que fin d'un
projet qui qui grandit en fait on ne
s'en sert un nouveau projet qu'on a créé
cette année on a l'habitude des projets
sont repris d'année en année mais nous
on a décidé de le créer nous-mêmes et du
coup on est tombé bien cette idée de
oued que le projet remet finalement
qu'il a qui grandit au fil des mois on
précise qu'il ya six autres étudiants
sur ce projet on n'a pas pu tous vous
accueillir ici on va les sites est liée
à jessica oscars
robin katia et johanna j'en ai pas
oublié ses bons en plus de vous trois
alors vous faites partie tous d'une
association qui s'appelle poèmes pour
paris où est étudiant en médecine
solidarité quelles sont les missions de
cette association
berti alors c'est une association de
sécurité à la fois locale et
internationale du coup au niveau local
on organise plusieurs différents
événements qui touchent différents
publics les maisons de retraite les
enfants on a un projet avec l'hôpital
des nounours pour les enfants de
maternelle
on a des projets de solidarité même à
paris où on va voir les gens qui vivent
dans la rue et au niveau international
avec les projets l'été comme le nôtre et
ils y arrivent à temps plein d'autres
pays
voilà alors sur place mais l'un et les
actions aux côtés d'une association
bolivienne pour le coup qui s'appelle
nous quand chic de mots peut-être aussi
sur cette association qui et quel est
son but à cette association a les yeux
et tristan en fait c'est une association
qui est dans la banlieue de cochabamba
et en fait il ya plusieurs
mendiants plusieurs familles qui sont
associés à cette association très bien
et en fait elle leur permet d'avoir par
exemple est une création d'un potager
création d'une ludothèque en fait ça
leur permet d'avoir un cadre pour mieux
vivre faire des échanges ce genre de
trucs pour mener des actions sur faso et
c'est primordial de s'associer à une
association locale pour les coups bas ça
nous permet d'être en relation directe
avec des gens dans le besoin en fait fin
du coup il enfin on pourra y des 300
familles concrètement qui viendront
chaque jour voilà dans plusieurs
domaines alors quand vous avez créé ce
projet parler de ce projet pourquoi
avoir choisi la bolivie qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous avez choisi william ait
choisi la bolivie plutôt qu'un autre
pays pour mener cette action bas de par
sa situation actuelle dans le monde
enfin pour donner des petits chiffres
c'est le deuxième pays le plus pauvre
d'amérique latine dont 40 % des gens qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
ce qui est quand même énorme et donc bah
enfin on se dit que là-bas ya vraiment
de l'aide à apporter et il ya plein
d'autres raisons comme les inégalités
notamment entre urbaines et rurales
il a plus d'école aussi sur place que
des cols on peut parler aussi d'être du
travail des enfants qui est légal en
bolivie nuit à l'âge de 10 ans ce qui
est le chiffre le plus bas au monde
je crois en nos équipes notre votée en
2010 justement pour abc chiffres là a
dit ce qu'ils étaient avant à 14 et on
peut citer également une situation
sanitaire qui est alarmante
ayano l'eau potable en fait elle est
justement pas potable 80% de la
population qui boit de l'eau et non
courantes et d'accords infectés avec qui
transmet plein de maladies donc aussi
l'association qui est sur place et
permet ainsi d un assainissement de
l'eau genre de truc est également les
infrastructures hospitalières sont enfin
sont pas forcément accessible à tous par
exemple dans pas mal de cas ils doivent
à l'hôpital le plus proche avec ses
tubes seulement par voie fluviale
ce qui paraît impensable en france quoi
alors sur place justement vous y serez
en juillet
vous donnerez de votre temps dans un
centre communautaire de cochabamba c'est
la troisième ville du pays le troisième
ville de la bolivie quel type d'action
vous allez mener sur place alors sur
place
nous on va participer à la création du
troisième potager de l'association donc
c'est des potagers qui permettent aux
familles vraiment d'être presque
autonome est long mais les ont quasiment
toutes les nourritures qui vient de là
donc on va participer à la construction
ils ont déjà commencé mais nous on va
continuer arrivé là bas on va faire de
la main d'oeuvre quoi et après on va
faire du social il ya 300 familles qui
sont aidées par l'association donc nous
on va aller voir les familles on va
parler avec eux on va essayer de les
aider comme on peut et on va participer
à la construction d'une ludothèque
c'est un endroit pour que les enfants et
du soutien scolaire et aussi des jeux du
numérique et tout ça et on va participer
à la construction de tous à
l'installation mais vous resterez tout
le mois de juillet sur place presqu'un
mois alors un voyage comme celui là se
prépare avant on imagine comment on
prépare une telle action en france
comment on prépare les choses avant de
partir en bolivie en juillet il ya un
gros programme d'abord en octobre on a
le on trouve l'association
après on distribue à chacune des
personnes qui est dans le pôle un
travail d'accord après surtout la grosse
partie du projet c'est de récolter des
fonds en fait pour les apporter là bas
parce qu'il 500 euros je crois sur ce
projet voilà à peu près pour la
construction surtout de la ludothèque et
aussi du potager qui n'ont pas mal
d'argent et en fait on va leur donner
l'argent à l'association et on voit
juste voir la génèse en fait la
construction de ces choses là parce que
ça prend du temps il me serais déjà
parti
et justement pour récolter cet argent il
ya des actions conclut admis au 1000 en
place depuis la genèse du projet ont
fait on fait des stands que ce soit à
notre faculté sur des marchés on vend de
la nourriture principalement pour
essayer de récolter des fonds
on essaie de rechercher des partenariats
avec des entreprises
c'est pas toujours évident et on va le
vent va lancer une cagnotte en ligne
pour les particuliers qui seraient
défiscalisées on espère que femme on
espère récolter des dons comme ça très
bien alors il est d'ici juillet vous
reste quoi faire du coup ben c'est un
principalement récolté après tout ce qui
est santé enfin se vacciner et tout ça
et voilà c'est toute une logistique soit
vacciné peut-être des papiers de faire
aussi avant de partir des visas c'est
votre
c'est votre cinq domaines où est du coup
comment on commence à se commence à
aller voir en fait on a une pharmacie
qui nous aident en fait ils nous donnent
les vallées vaccin est donc juste
regarder le carnet de santé pour voir si
tout le monde est vacciné et il n'y a
pas de visa en fait oui voilà quand on a
pris nos billets d'avion et la voilà il
nous reste les pmi de vaccination
affaire est sûre et logistiques ce nom
on est à peu près bon deja question vous
parlez tous espagnols
on apprend il ya plusieurs personnes
bilingues donc donné le ton qu'on sera
là c'est ce qu'on fait on sera par
groupes de trois personnes à chaque fois
très le cas au moins une personne qui
sera bilingue de chacun des groupes
eh bien merci à vous trois nominés ray
berthe de bertille pardon terna et
tristan garcia merci d'avoir été avec
nous des étudiants en deuxième année de
médecine à ubs cuit avec six autres de
vos camarades vous allez partir en
bolivie en juillet pour mener une action
humanitaire ce projet c'est millas est à
retrouver sur la page facebook qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci d'avoir été avec nous pour notre
portrait de la semaine nous allons
danser avec les dix jeunes yvelinois ils
ont entre 14 et 17 ans et font du hip
hop et meltin urban crous et le nom de
leur groupe une compagnie créée il ya
quatre ans par aurélie aldebert
rencontre signée mélanie poker
répéter encore et encore inlassablement
un quotidien pour ces jeunes yvelinois
depuis quatre ans il forme le melting
urban coup une compagnie de jeunes
danseurs sélectionnés sur audition
je
une compagnie récent créé par aurélie
aldebert leur chorégraphe et professeur
de hip hop ça c'est pas par terre et
eléonore ça se prend au pis s'il vous
plaît le tout premier objectif de cette
compagnie c'était de permettre à des
jeunes de monter sur scène et
et de et de montrer ce qu'ils avaient
dans le ventre et ce qu'ils avaient
envie de monter sur scène et de partager
des scènes vraiment avec d'autres
groupes que ce soit des groupes hip hop
mais voir aussi s'ouvrir sur d'autres
styles de danse comme la danse classique
le moderne le jazz le contemporain
dix jeunes de 14 à 17 ans qui ont fait
de la danse un loisir quasi
professionnelle deux à trois
entraînements hebdomadaires et des
stages il jongle leur passion avec leur
quotidien de collégiens et lycéens
on s'est fait là on a des trainings 1h30
technique et trois heures en compagnie
heureusement fin heureusement c'est le
samedi les trainings en compagnie mais
c'est assez compliqué parce que
justement 17 ans en terminale j'ai le
bac et le travail voilà mes origines
nous dit toujours que c'est d'abord
l'école et ensuite la danse jusqu'il
toujours en fait parce que je suis très
compétitive donc faire que du loisir je
pense ça me manquerait quelque chose
donc travailler beaucoup ça j'aime bien
debasement elle a dansé une passion j'ai
envie d'en faire mon métier plus tard
du coup pour moi c'est pas du tout une
contrainte est de pouvoir entrer dans
une compagnie aussi jeune
c'était un rêve de petite fille ce
samedi ils passent un nouveau concours
des rendez-vous qu'il présente une à
deux fois par mois
cette fois ils sont aux scènes urbaines
johnny cypher on a fait un concours
chorégraphique parce que ça donne un
challenge pour les compagnies mais avant
tout c'est le plaisir de monter sur
scène c'est le plaisir de voilà ont créé
une chorégraphie ont créé un show et on
le présente devant la famille devant les
amis
bah un petit peu stressé mais
ça va c'est de l'adrénaline positif donc
non là c'est on est motivé pour donner
le meilleur de nous-mêmes et va faire
kiffer public en fait huit groupes sont
en compétition pour la catégorie junior
les melting urban cruiser les troisièmes
à se présenter sur scène
[Musique]
pour cette deuxième édition il termine
3e prochain objectif la finale de haut
sauf crew pro le 17 mars prochain avec
dans le viseur le mois de mai les
qualifications du hip hop international
france à orléans pour tenter de partir à
las vegas et du judo à coignières avant
de ceux acquittés plus de 200 jeunes
âgés de 4 à 12 ans se sont affrontés sur
les tatamis du gymnase du moulin à vent
ce week end une compétition qui a réuni
une vingtaine de clubs des yvelines pas
de résultats officiels mais des combats
pour apprendre je vous propose d'écouter
ce professeur de judo à coignières au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
alors le but de cette compétition c'est
pour que dans le temps puisse rencontrer
des enfants qui ne connaissent pas de
d'autres clubs et en même temps qui va
prendre un petit peu plus que c'est que
le judo par une compétition paula ya un
arbitre
donc les règles sont un peu plus
expliqué plus facilement pas s'ils sont
deux passes à une personne un adulte
donc du coup c'est plus facile pour eux
de comprendre c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal à suivre ce soir sur notre
chaîne un nouveau numéro de mode
d'emploi présentées par aurélie rose une
émission consacrée aux métiers de
l'audiovisuel
ce journal est à retrouver en replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]